Complete the square on the
general quadratic equation.
We have ax squared plus bx
plus c is equal to 0.
So whenever I complete the
square, actually whenever I
deal with any of these types
of quadratic equations, I
always like to not have an a, or
a non 1 coefficient, on the
x squared terms. So let's make
it into a 1 coefficient.
And the easiest way to do
that is just divide
everything by a.
So we divide every term on the
left side by a, and of course
we have to divide the right
side by a as well.
And so the left side
will become x
squared plus b over ax.
And then I'll write c
over a over here.
So we have some room to add and
subtract things so we can
really complete the square.
So plus c over a is equal to 0
divided by a, which is just
going to be equal to 0.
Now when we complete the
square, we've seen this
multiple times before, what
we want to do is take the
coefficient on the x term right
here, it's b over a,
take half of it.
This right here is two
times b over 2a.
Right?
The 2's cancel out.
This is just 2 times
b over 2a.
So you take half of it, half
of b over a is b over 2a.
You take half of it, and then
you square it, and you add it
right here.
So plus b squared-- Let
me write it this way.
b over 2a squared.
And of course I can't just add
something to one side of the
equation, that would change
the equation.
I also either have to add it
to the other side, or just
subtract it from the same side
that I'm adding it to.
So I'll also subtract
the b over 2a
squared just like that.
Now, the whole point of doing
this is so these first three
terms right here are a perfect
square trinomial.
That's what completing the
square is all about.
And we've seen the pattern
multiple times.
If I have, let's say, m plus n
squared-- and I'm using m and
n so we don't get confused
with the a's and b's
and x's over here.
But if I have m plus n squared,
we've seen multiple
times, that's going to be equal
to m squared plus 2mn
plus n squared.
And here we have that
pattern now.
That's the whole point behind
completing the square.
taking half of b over a--
that's b over 2a-- and then
squaring it and adding it
right here.
We now fit that pattern.
m is x.
n is b over 2a.
And 2mn, if I take an x times a
b over 2a, and multiply that
by 2, I get b over ax.
So this expression, right here,
this trinomial, the
first three terms, it is a
perfect square trinomial, and
we can write it as x plus
b over 2a squared.
And then of course we
have all this other
business right here.
And then of course we
have all of this
other stuff right here.
Which is negative b over,
and let me just actually
square it for you.
So b over 2a squared
is negative b
squared over 4a squared.
And then I have this
plus c over a.
But let's write it with the
same denominator here.
So I could have c over a, or I
could multiply the numerator
and the denominator by 4a.
So if I multiply the numerator
by 4a, I get 4ac.
If I multiply the denominator
by 4a, I get 4a squared.
And the whole reason why I
multiplied the numerator and
the denominator by 4a was
so that we have the same
denominator right here.
And, of course, that is going
to be equal to 0.
And we could simplify it a
little bit more, or actually,
well yeah we'll just simplify
it next in the next step.
We don't want to skip
too many steps here.
So you have x plus b
over 2a squared.
And then we could say, plus-- we
could put the 4ac first, so
we could say-- actually let's
just say, plus negative b
squared, plus 4ac, all of that
over 4a squared is equal to 0.
I didn't put the 4ac first,
I just put the negative b
squared there.
Now let's isolate this
squared binomial on
the left hand side.
And the easiest way we can do
that is to subtract this thing
from both sides of
the equation.
So let's do that.
So you can imagine if we add
b-- let me do this in a
different color.
If we were to add positive b
squared minus 4ac over 4a
squared on the left hand side,
those will cancel out and
we're also going to add it
on the right hand side.
Positive b squared minus
4ac over 4a squared.
Anything I do the left I
have to do the right.
What do we end up with?
We end up with, on the left
hand side, these two guys
cancel out.
We have the same denomenator,
when you add the numerators,
that cancels with that.
The 4ac cancels with the
negative 4ac, these just
completely cancel out.
And on the left hand side,
you just have x
plus b over 2a squared.
And on the right hand side, you
have that being equal to b
squared minus-- let me do
that in a blue color.
b squared minus 4ac, all of
that over 4a squared.
Now the next thing we probably
want to do, if we want to
really solve for x, is to take
the square root of both sides
of this equation.
So let's do that.
Let's take the square root of
both sides of this equation.
And if, when we do that-- We
don't want to only take the
positive square root because x
plus b be over 2a could be a
negative number, or it could
be a positive number.
So we want to take
the positive and
negative square root.
So we could say that the square
root, we could put the
positive or negative here or,
since we're taking the square
root of both sides,
we could put the
positive or negative there.
If you put the positive or
negative on both sides, it's
really just telling you
the same thing.
It really is all the different
combinations.
If the negative square root over
here equals the negative
square root over here, then it's
just another combination
of the different positives
and negatives.
So you could just write it as,
this square root is equal to
the plus or minus square
root of b squared
minus 4ac over 4a squared.
Now what does this
simplify to?
Well, the left hand side just
becomes x plus b over 2a is
equal to-- and now it
gets interesting.
And you might even start
recognizing parts of it.
So let's take the plus or minus
square root of the top.
What is that going to be?
And you could just take the plus
or minus only of the top
because, once again, the
same principles apply.
There's no reason why you have
to do a plus or minus over a
plus and minus and a plus or
minus on the left hand side.
There's only one combination
here, where there's only one
plus or minus on
the numerator.
I apologize if that
confuses you.
So let's write this as the plus
or minus square root of b
squared minus 4ac over--
What's the square
root of 4a a squared?
Well, it's just going
to be 2a.
Right?
The square root of 4 is 2.
The square root of
a squared is a.
And we're almost there.
To solve for x, we just have
to subtract b over 2a from
both sides.
We just have to subtract b over
2a from both sides of
this equation.
The left hand side, we just
end up with our x.
And then the right hand side,
we have a negative b over 2a
plus or minus the square root
of b squared minus 4ac-- all
of that over 2a.
Since we have the same
denominator, we can write this
as negative b plus or minus the
square root of b squared
minus 4ac-- all of
that over 2a.
And we're done.
We've solved for the x's and you
see there's actually two
solutions here.
There's one where you take the
positive square root, and
there's another solution
where you take the
negative square root.
If this square root exists,
and if the positive and
negative-- and if it's
not 0, you're
going to have two solutions.
And this, right here, this
result we have is-- Look, you
give me any quadratic equation,
you give me the a,
the b, and the c, we could now
substitute it into this
formula essentially we just
derived right here, and I'll
give you the roots, I'll give
you the x's for that quadratic
equation-- the x's that satisfy
that quadratic equation.
And this formula, right here,
for solving any quadratic
equation is called the
quadratic formula.
And you could see it just
comes straight out of
completing the square.
There's no mystery,
magic here.
But it's easily one of the
most useful formulas in
mathematics.
And I'm usually not
a huge proponent
of memorizing things.
But it probably will benefit
you in life if you did.
Hope you enjoyed that.